hey didn't you hear Cody's doing a
charity where he runs was it a mile per
thousand mile per thousand yeah
um This song is called
we're donating five thousand dollars
so you run a five extra five miles wait
actually yes who is we are are you
serious right now yeah right yeah yeah
wait what is this real or is it yeah
actually and everybody go run it up so
Cody has to run no Jillian miles go to
Cody trains Luke can you pull it up and
we'll just I'm like gonna cry this is
[__] awesome why are you gonna cry
well because like we're not like we have
two weeks left I really thought that
we'd get to 50K pretty easily oh and I'm
having a hard time like getting like you
know oh no Finish Line here come on now
all right so you're at 35
971 now so let's go ahead and throw a
Fiverr in there this is sick because by
donating through TMG I guess it's also
me donating yeah yeah but hey half of
it's me